What are your thoughts on using colostrum with growth factors
for someone with hormone-positive breast cancer?
Clostrum is a common supplement these days
and colostrum does have growth factors.
Clostrum is going to be a dairy-based product.
And it does have growth factors,
and that's really the benefit of it.
It can help heal your gutted things.
So it's typically not recommended for anybody
with any type of cancer.
Now, if you had to take colostrum for a short period time
to help with something else, I don't
see that as a real problem.
But to be honest, while you're in the throes of cancer,
there can be dangers to that.
Now, I would say also that if it depends
on where you're at with your cancer with any of these two,
even with glutamine, let's say your cancer is in full remission,
which you have really damaged gut.
And you want to take glutamine for a short period of time.
Is it OK to do that?
Well, yes, probably.
I mean, there's no way to absolutely know
whether it's going to be a perfect situation for anybody.
But using common sense, if you're
trying to accomplish another task with a product
for a short period of time, if you're going
to take colostrum because you've read this thing,
they'd be really good for you.
And you want to be on it on a regular basis.
If your cancer is a complete remission,
then I would think twice about that.
But if your cancer wasn't complete remission,
you were doing really well, but now you're
trying to heal something else, testing it out
and going out at a first short period of time.
I don't see that as a big problem.